GUESS THAT NOTHING WILL HAPPEN
UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION.
>> MILLIONS OF AMERICAN FAMILIES
FAMILIES, AND IT TOOK EFFECT IN
MARCH AS PART OF THE CARES ACT
FOR CORONAVIRUS RELIEF.
MANY EXPERTS SAY WE ARE ON THE
VERGE OF A FULL STOMACH FULL
BLOWN ELECTION CRISIS.
GILLIAN TURNER IS LIVE WITH MORE
MORE.
>> SO YOU ARE RIGHT, THE
GOVERNMENT’S BAN ON EVICTIONS IS
SET TO EXPIRE IN JUST A FEW
HOURS AND THEN 20 MILLION
AMERICAN FAMILIES ARE FACING THE
THREAT OF BEING KICKED OUT OF
THEIR HOMES, SOMETHING THAT
EXPERTS HAVE BEEN RINGING ALARM
BELLS ABOUT IN RECENT WEEKS
BECAUSE IN THIS MONTH ALONE, 32%
OF AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS AMIDST
EITHER THEIR RENT OR MORTGAGE
PAYMENT AND IT’S A STAGGERING
NUMBER.
EXPERTS ALSO SAY AMERICA’S
BIGGEST CITIES WILL BE HIT THE
WORST WHICH IS WHERE MOST
RENTERS LIVE.
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO GO OVER A
CLIFF HERE IN THIS CITY IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE POTENTIALLY LOSING
THEIR HOUSING AND WE HAVE TO
STOP IT.
>> LOS ANGELES IS ANOTHER
POTENTIAL HOT SPOT ON THE VERGE
OF CRISIS.
>> EVEN THOUGH I’M RECEIVING
UNEMPLOYMENT IT’S STILL NOT THE
SAME AMOUNT I WAS BEFORE.
MY RENT, ABOUT 30% OF WHAT MY
INCOME WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC.
>> DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP WANTS
TO INCLUDE HOUSING IN THE NEXT
SUPPLEMENTAL BILL THAT’S WORKING
ITS WAY THROUGH THE CAPITOL HILL
NIGHT.
>> IF WE PASS EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE, WE HELP FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS PAY THE BILLS, STAY
IN THEIR HOMES AND STABILIZE THE
RENTAL MARKET AND KEEP UP, HELP
OWNERS KEEP UP WITH HER PROPERTY
AND MORTGAGES.
>> THEY CLAIM MORE MORTGAGES
WILL BE MORE SICK AMERICANS.
>> FORCING PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
HOMES DURING A PANDEMIC WILL
MAKE A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
WORSE.
WIDESPREAD HOUSING DISRUPTION
WILL ALSO AFFECT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
KEEPING OUR ECONOMY GOING.
>> NEITHER SHAMIR NOR WARREN CAN
RESIST DIGGING REPUBLICANS.
>> WE ARE JUST DAYS AWAY FROM A
HOUSING CRISIS THAT COULD BE
PRESENTED IF MITCH McCONNELL
STOPS STALLING IN THE SENATE ACT
ACT.
>> NOW WE HAVE TALKED TO
REPUBLICANS ALL MORNING LONG ON
CAPITOL HILL AND AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THEY ALL SAY
KEEPING AMERICANS IN THEIR HOMES
IS OUR TOP PRIORITY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND A MASS SCALE